this is just a quick video to say thank
you thank you to all our patrons people
who give money it really really does
make a difference so thank you so much
if you're one of those people who's
contributed any amount of money thank
you again
if you haven't shame on you what do you
think you're doing please support us but
no seriously if you're one of those
people thank you so much thank you to
our sponsors thank you to everybody who
contributes and supports the podcast it
means a world both to myself and
Constantino if it's under 10 pounds it
doesn't count yeah I see you see he's
Russian he's limited so but again we
really do appreciate it
no we really do guys and there's one
person we wanted to thank in particular
she is a youtuber herself Tara Smith who
helped us with our website and a store
where you can go and buy mugs you know
phone cases all that kind of stuff she's
created a great website for us and
actually the content that she puts out
on YouTube herself he's absolutely
brilliant talking about all this work
stuff from her perspective she's an
Aussie and a brilliant woman so make
sure you go and follow her and listen to
her stuff on YouTube as well and as
Frances says we really appreciate we've
got some huge support from a few of you
as you know Frances and I don't any none
of the money that you guys give us goes
to into our pockets we pay a producer we
pay for equipment stuff like that we
don't actually take anything out of the
show so you guys are making the show
happen and thank you very much for doing
that make sure you go and follow tear on
YouTube isn't that a communist model
that they're making it happen through
their contributions it's not true anyway
I mean we're obviously putting all that
money into your cocaine habit yeah
absolutely that's why I've got big nose
anyway guys see you next week